بعد اكثر من اربعه عقود في العاصمه
البريطانيه لندن اعلنت مكتبه الساقي انها
ستغلق ابوابها نهايه ديسمبر لتنتهي بذلك
تجربه مضيئه في خدمه الثقافه العربيه في
اوروبا
[موسيقى]
بعد اربع 44 عاما جمعت خلالها مكتبه
الساقيه
من مختلف انحاء العالم تغلق المكتبه نهايه
ديسمبر محلها الاكبر في اوروبا
لم تعد قادره على اكمال مشوارها بسبب
اعباء بريطانيا الاقتصاديه المتزايده
العرب
[موسيقى]
سياسيه في المنطقه العربيه
للتعبير عن ارائهم او احتجاجاتهم
ما في حدا يكسرنا قزايز المكتب يكسروا لنا
الواجهه لانه في كتاب معجبه او حديث يقول
لك ممنوع الموسيقى ليه حاكيني موسيقى
[موسيقى]
لا يسمع احد خبر اغلاق المكتبه دون شعوري
بغصه خساره كنز ثقافي
القراءه واشتغل في المكاتبك عده
تتركو سلوى مكتبه الساقيه على امل تسليم
شعلتها الثقافيه لجيل شاب يقدر ما انتجته
المكتبه من تجربه غنيه تشرف الثقافه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
في عقول الكثير من الزائرين الى هذه
المكتبه مكتبه دار الساقي تغلق ابوابها
بعد اكثر من اربعين عاما تطورت فيها
التكنولوجيا بسرعه فائقه جعلت من
المطبوعات الورقيه والمحافظه على شغفي بها
عبئا في ظل اوضاع اقتصاديه صعبه تمر بها
بريطانيا
عروب عبد الحق العربيه